what is the thinking behind this plan
cooked up by the Lib Dems in the SMP
well first of all this is an offer to
the country by our leader Joe Swanson
who's trying to provide some leadership
here through the gridlock that we have
clearly this do-or-die pledge of the
prime minister to leave the European
Union by the end of October is dead but
the question is what do we do next we've
got to break the gridlock and as a party
the Liberal Democrats have always been
clear that we want to stop brexit now
the only way we can stop brexit in this
Parliament is through a people's vote
referring this issue back to the people
but it's quite clear now that it's
highly unlikely that in this current
Parliament we're going to be able to
achieve that we've put down 17
amendments in this Parliament to provide
for people's vote and we voted for it 7
times which is the number of times it's
been put before Parliament we've never
hit the numbers and now that you've got
19 Labour MPs who have voted for the
Prime Minister's hard brexit who will
not support a people's vote well you
probably disagree with the pitch there's
a hard break set and many those
neighbouring worlds as well I would say
did on the table but the point is
they're not going to support a people's
vote and then half of the former
independent or the former Conservative
MPs like Philip Hammond also will not
support a people's vote and therefore in
this Parliament it simply does not look
like we are going to be able to achieve
that and indeed it looks more likely
that you would be able to do that in a
new Parliament our really important
thing about our bill by the way there
are three things to bear in mind about
this first of all it takes no deal off
the table so this only kicks in a
general election on the 9th of December
only kicks in if an extension to the
31st of January has been granted
secondly at the moment under the fits
term Parliament's at the Prime Minister
if there was an early election he gets
to choose the date of the general
election this bill that we've put
forward actually fixes the date of the
general election for the 9th and the
last thing is of course there will not
be requisite time to be able to get his
withdrawal agreement bill through
there's no way that this can be rammed
through so you've got three you've got
three really important things there
tapes no deal off the table fixes
legally the date of an election and
ensures that we don't see the Prime
Minister trying to ram his withdrawal
agreement through the House of Commons
and it then
refers this issue back to the people so
we can end the gridlock in Westminster
because we've got a responsibility they
provide this not just a legislature that
functions but a government that
functions and can only really do that it
seems not to do general election
listening to what you say it feels as if
the real aim of this move to support an
election is a to try and stop wrecks
like happening or scare the potentially
and secondly to try and make sure that
the Prime Minister's brexit deal has no
chance of getting through so why on
earth where the government support it
well the government claims it wants an
election that is the stipulated
stipulated aim of the Prime Minister net
and then if a deal doesn't go through
then they want an election that's a
critical difference but they're not
going to be able to get the deal through
it must the same read in that kind of
timeframe that you and I know and you're
a seasoned observer of all of this that
there are many stages of a bill and
there are many amendments that could be
tabled to this one thing by the way I
want to be absolutely clear about this
bill the principle that we have used in
putting it together is to mess as little
as possible with the fixed terms upon a
fixed term Parliament act and that means
that it is being drafted very tightly so
there has been this issue raised about
well would you seek to change the
franchise through this bill through its
passage say for example to add 16 and 17
year olds the register or EU citizens
now we've got no objection to that those
two things in principle but it would be
at this outside the scope of this bill
and we don't have a luxury of time to
give a requisite scrutiny to those
things now the only way that this can
achieve the ambitions that you want is
if a general election effectively
producers Jeremy Corbyn Prime Minister
well I couldn't disagree more about that
what you thought would be a Lib Dem
majority government but what I am saying
is is ultimately we have to pass this
back to the people so what do you become
that you think well the outcome that we
want of course will be fighting for a
majority Liberal Democrat government and
if that is delivered we will immediately
stop this chaos and revoke the article
it doesn't however however if we don't
have the numbers in a new House of
Commons to revoke article 50 of course
will still be campaigning for a people's
vote and this is the point is we don't
really know I mean Jeremy Corbyn in
number 10 but this is the thing you're
talking 20th century politics
we're in the 21st century and if you
listen to people like John Curtis for
example widely acknowledged to be the
biggest polling guru in a country he is
saying we are in full party politics now
and no one knows what will happen at
that General and I both know that by far
the most likely scenario is either Boris
Johnson in number 10 he will not go on a
second referendum or Jeremy Corbyn who
might
so your plan defends depends on Jeremy
call in getting the keys to nominee no
it doesn't our plan depends on us
delivering as many liberal Democrat MPs
as we can at the next Parliament how
many do you think would be a realistic
proposition well I think ultimately the
public get to decide this I know what
you're trying to do trying to get me to
say either I want Boris Johnson or
Jeremy Corbyn as Prime Minister and I
think frankly the country's fed up with
that choice they have a new person on
the block next generation politician a
breath of fresh air compared to the
baggage that the two other individuals
I've just mentioned to carry which is
Joe Swinson and ultimately the public
will get to determine this and you know
if I start throwing figures around doing
so well the Liberal Democrats them
they're gonna get this or that
ultimately the whole point of referring
this back to the people in a general
election is that they are really fed up
with the impasse and the mess and we've
got to front up with people and say look
we've got a legislature and we've got a
government that is not doing its
constitutional function and now we could
all sit back and say it'd be very
comfortable for us to carry on taking
our salaries and carrying on with this
chaos but Joseph Winston's judgment is
that is not in the national interest and
that is why she has put forward this
bill today now and you've obviously got
the support of the SNP yes support this
as well labour of course have been
silent on this so far is that because
she talked and about it and they
rejected it or did you just not approach
them about it at all
no so everybody then over the course of
it I mean obviously this is a
fast-moving thing so the course of the
last 12 hours or so different people
have been spoken to I mean look you're
right so if I agree with you this is not
going to happen unless one of the two
main parties at least one of them is
with labour whether they backed this and
they both say that they want a general
election and we have given the vehicle
through which you can have that general
election so I think the problem that the
Labour Party's got it is to summon you
know to some extent a bit divided on
this issue as to whether or not to have
a general election or not and let us
wait and see what the government says
I mean I did think that Niki Morgan's
interview with you earlier was something
you know quite something given that in
her former guise as a Treasury select
committee chair she would have been
arguing for a very different course of
action and it was interesting because I
don't think while she you know you'd
expect the government to go this is a
gimmick astana it's not read the bill
Nicky she did not rule out the
government necessarily playing not
playing ball with this bill the thing
that she has realized she had to realize
this because she is somebody who's been
very critical of our own pride her own
Prime Minister and I think has said in
the past on the record but this is
somebody who to put it generously is
economical with the truth and the
problem that most members of parliament
have with his proposals there are many
but saying well let's have this general
election on December 12th is that there
is no guarantee in law that he will
actually follow through on that promise
once Parliament has passed a dissolution
motion it empowers the Prime Minister
under the terms of the fixed own
Parliament act to have the general a
general election netted data they're
choosing because to use the language it
is thumb by Proclamation by the Queen on
the advice of the Prime Minister and we
know that this Prime Minister is not shy
about misleading the Queen and putting
her in a compromising position and you
saw that over the poor agait ssin the
unlawful prorogation of parliament one
final question for you I know you've
been looking at something called a
Wilson Doctrine which is a convention
that MPs communications shouldn't be
intercepted by the intelligence service
what is it that you've been looking at
here well last weekend number 10 briefed
to a Sunday newspaper that they were
investigating with the suggestion that
there was intelligence gathering and
surveillance of members of Parliament's
contacts with the governments of other
countries particularly those in the
European Union now that was designed to
try and suggest that somehow there was
some cooperation between members of
parliament and other governments which
was wholly false and the members of
parliament accused have rejected that
but I have put down parliamentary
questions I've written to the prime
minister and asked him to confirm what
investigations have been happening and
what the legal basis is for it because
every Prime Minister since Howard
Wilson's time
has given a statement and guaranteed
that members of Parliament's
communications with other governments
which are necessary for us to perform
our function I'm the from shadow foreign
secretary the Liberal Democrats I can't
do my job properly unless I have
contacts with other governments to
inform our foreign policy position but
every other Prime Minister has given a
statement observing this doctrine that
you do not carry out surveillance of
members of parliament and the Prime
Minister so far in spite of these
questions and in spite of the fact
number 10 has been briefing that they
have been investigating MPs has refused
to give the usual statement saying he
divided by that doctrine and what this
suggests is that the Prime Minister
and/or others in government are carrying
out surveillance on members of
parliament and that takes us in a very
dangerous direction a very authoritarian
direction and I'd argue is deeply
undemocratic and so the Prime Minister
needs to answer the question why have
you not given a statement like every
other Prime Minister in recent times
saying that you will observe that
doctrine like everyone else if we don't
get an answer I think we're entitled to
presume that he is authorizing the
surveillance of members of polymer which
is wholly unacceptable and undemocratic